[Music]
this is the london headquarters of the
freemasons a secret society that has
existed for hundreds of years i want to
learn more about this mysterious group
so what better way than to try and join
i decided to knock on the large bronze
door at the front but no answer the
actual entrance was around the side
through a modern set of automatic doors
the freemasons welcomed random visits
from the public after a quick security
check i was given a yellow lanyard i had
made it inside and was now free to
explore i began wondering the marble
corridors of the grand lodge
unsupervised on the walls hung paintings
of former members including george
washington being a monday morning the
building was relatively quiet i couldn't
help thinking that for a secret society
it wasn't very secretive where were the
rogued monks or hooded acolytes that
were here to drag me away the freemasons
had kindly signposted their headquarters
with directions after passing through
more corridors and a flight of stairs i
discovered a small meeting room with its
distinctive checkered floor as i
ascended the upper levels i eventually
found the room i've been searching for
the grand temple the innermost sanctum
of british freemasonry this is the room
where the freemasons gather together and
engage in sacred ritual the hall was
resplendent with a golden throne in the
center and lavish mosaics adorning the
ceiling they were decorated with masonic
symbols and emblems including an
all-seeing eye above a pentagram i was
partially hoping to have stumbled in on
a cabal of bloodthirsty satanists but
quite the contrary feeling a little
deflated i spent the rest of my visit
browsing the gift shop admiring
freemason merchandise and trinkets with
a souvenir mug in hand i couldn't help
but feel that i'd missed something how
had it been so easy to enter what really
goes on behind closed doors and why does
a secret society need a gift shop there
was one thing for it i had to try and
become a freemason myself
who are the freemasons what is their
history and what do they believe
freemasons traced their routes back to
medieval britain to a guild of stone
cutters the masons were just one of
several medieval guilds like the
goldsmiths merchants and even
fishmongers in every town a guild would
have its own building known as a lodge
where members would gather together to
discuss work and socialize each member
was to represent their lodge and
contribute to its upkeep in the
following centuries however the medieval
guild system began to decline but for
some reason the masons survived it's
believed that the group began to accept
people from outside the stone cutting
profession patrons that just wanted to
support the guild and most importantly
help finance it these new members tended
to be from the aristocracy who had lots
of cash at their disposal the grand
lodge in london was founded in 1717. by
this time the organization had evolved
into something very different from its
medieval roots instead it was comprised
almost entirely of aristocrats with new
lodges being set up across britain's
burgeoning empire the freemasons as they
came to be known was a place for the
rich and powerful to socialize and do
business
it was rather similar to a private
gentleman's club which was all the rage
in london at the time whilst they have
much in common with an elite gentleman's
club including the fact that they don't
accept women the freemasons have various
traditions and beliefs that separate
them from other societies freemasons
adhere to a distinct philosophy of
self-improvement and personal growth
central to this are the various
freemason texts a collection of books
and teachings designed to stimulate
deeper thought members belong to a
community of like-minded men who help
encourage one's spiritual development
the organization also places a big
emphasis on philanthropy and is well
known for donating vast sums of money to
charity now freemasonry is not a
religion per se but it does advocate the
belief in a higher power freemasons
don't like to use the word god as it's
too aligned with christianity instead
they prefer great architect of the
universe another nod to their stonemason
origins symbols are a big part of
freemasonry take their logo for example
the square and compass the square is set
to represent the lodge master and the
compass points represent both senior and
junior members others say that the
square represents honesty and the
compass represents integrity and loyalty
there are hundreds of these symbols each
reflecting a value or doctrine that the
group holds like the beehive which
reminds members to work together to
ensure the fraternity success or the
gavel which stresses the authority held
by the lodge master often these symbols
are gathered together creating unique
spreads known as tracing boards these
tracing boards are visual aids designed
to teach junior members about the
beliefs of the group a bit like a
where's waldo of esoteric doctrine
one symbol that struck me was the two
stone ashlars the rough cube represents
the mind before freemasonry and the
smooth cube represents the mind
afterwards i suppose i'm the rough cube
at the moment a naive mind that has not
yet been indoctrinated into the
freemason brotherhood i had to smoothen
my brain and finally make my application
to join
having acquired a magazine and a
beginner's pamphlet i explored ways to
become a freemason traditionally
newcomers must be recommended by an
existing member but sadly i don't know
anyone who's a freemason at least i
think so i went for the second option
nowadays you can apply online there are
four requirements to become a freemason
be a man check be over 18 so far so good
believe in a higher power i'm an atheist
but i can work on that be of good moral
standing
i'll give myself a check within five
minutes i had registered to join all
that was left was to wait a member of
the freemasons would be in touch whilst
i waited i thought i'd get ahead of the
application process and do some
background reading turns out it takes a
lot of work to officially become a
freemason it's not really something you
can do in a week
applicants are subjected to a round of
interviews after which they're given a
task of memorizing a masonic ritual for
newcomers you must learn the ritual of
the entered apprentice this text
contains the basic precepts of
freemasonry here's an extract of what
you might be asked to memorize
our lodges are supported by three great
pillars which are called wisdom strength
and beauty wisdom to contrive strength
to support
and beauty to adorn wisdom to conduct us
in all our undertakings strength to
support us under all our difficulties
and beauty to adorn the inward man
you'll be asked to memorize this in a
special initiation ceremony to help
you'll be given a tracing board with a
bunch of visual clues each board is
tailored to the specific piece of ritual
you must learn if you're able to
successfully memorize it then
congratulations you're now freemason
joining the freemasons requires a lot of
effort and dedication you must put in
hours of study and learn pages and pages
of sacred text and even if you do join
you're expected to attend all the
society meetings failure to do so and
you'll be asked to leave
one reason why it's so hard to join is
to deter people from sneaking in and
sharing their secrets but fortunately
many of their rituals can be found
online i guess it's difficult to run a
secret society when the internet exists
secrecy is an important tradition in
freemasonry it's even ingrained in their
motto
audi vide tache latin for hear c
be silent it's slogans like these that
have made the group so controversial and
why they're often the subject of
conspiracy theories the first group to
take issue with the freemasons was the
catholic church for one the vatican did
not approve of them calling god the
architect of the universe so in 1738
pope clement xii banned all catholics
from becoming a freemason but the main
wave of distrust began in the late 1700s
at that time a number of important
revolutions were taking place both
america and france had toppled their
monarchies inspired by the ideals of
equality liberty and democracy these
high-minded principles came from the
enlightenment a philosophical movement
that was popular among the aristocracy
people would gather for intellectual
debates wherever they could from coffee
houses to universities but especially in
masonic lodges over time people began to
grow suspicious of the freemasons and
soon connected them with the revolutions
sweeping the globe people believed that
somehow the freemasons were responsible
one of the first to expound these fears
was an englishman called john robinson
in his 1797 book proof of a conspiracy
he accused the freemasons of inciting
revolutions to gain power the same book
also accused a small bavarian book club
known as the illuminati of the same
crimes it gave birth to one of the
world's oldest conspiracy theories the
new world order which is the belief that
a powerful network of secret elites are
controlling world events whether or not
the freemasons are pulling the strings
is debatable but then again many
powerful historical figures have been
freemasons most notably george
washington the first president of the
united states other members include
benjamin franklin voltaire theodore
roosevelt winston churchill and a whole
slew of british monarchs this certainly
adds to the argument that the freemasons
might be behind world politics the truth
is however the freemasons have always
been a very large group even today there
aren't 6 million active members i don't
think it's too surprising to find a few
famous names on the list
the freemasons have been connected to a
wide range of conspiracy theories
including but not limited to faking the
moon landings flat earth satan worship
or that there are cults of reptilian
aliens in disguise while some of these
are ridiculous they have thrived due to
the organization's long tradition of
secrecy the freemasons are not willing
to share what goes on behind closed
doors such secrecy is inevitable to
breed skepticism and distrust
so how do we separate fact from fiction
what are the freemasons really up to my
pending application to become a
freemason was taking a while i hadn't
heard back from them so i decided to
take matters into my own hands i wanted
to see if i can get into a freemason
group without the hassle of actually
becoming a freemason
it was then when i stumbled across the
official facebook group of the london
freemasons for some reason the group's
posts were not switched to private i was
able to access conversations that were
not intended to be read by the public
what i discovered was rather surprising
it was pages and pages of freemason
cartoons crudely drawn comics they'd
made for each other with badly cropped
stock images and comic sans fonts of
course it was more than just these memes
many posts were linked to charity events
and blood drives and even online meetups
for members the freemason group was very
wholesome just a bunch of friends who
wanted to get together and raise money
for charity i'd finally reached the
bottom of the freemason rabbit hole
unless of course there's a secret secret
facebook group that remembers to switch
their posts to private
as i continued with my investigation i
got the feeling that the freemasons had
been a little misunderstood maybe i
stand against my youtube brethren here
on this one but i do not believe that
they're a malicious organization of
satan worshiping cultists instead it had
more in common with an upper class
gentleman's club the freemasons have
their secrets for sure but none that are
particularly scandalous the reality of
the freemasons is that it's a medieval
self-help group with a bunch of rituals
that you need to memorize
perhaps there are those who insist that
they're still hiding something dark or
that i haven't gone deep enough with my
search
maybe but then again how far do you need
to go until you find that there was
nothing there to begin with this is not
to say that every conspiracy or negative
opinion about the freemasons is false
just that a large portion is fantasy of
course there are things that i
personally take issue with for an
organization that preaches tolerance and
equality it seems hypocritical that they
still don't allow women to join what's
more these kinds of upper-class
institutions represent a wider problem
in society it's one of privileged and
gatekeeping just look at how many
british prime ministers studied the same
degree program at oxford
as for the freemasons i hope this video
is a kind of anti-conspiracy theory
there are times when reality is stranger
than fiction but this is not one of
those times the freemasons i believe are
far less mysterious than they're made
out to be i realized that my sympathetic
approach might make me seem a little
suspicious
maybe i'm part of the new world order
and i'm here promoting freemason
propaganda
i'm not
but i might be
up to you
hey thanks for watching i had a great
time making this one it's a different
style to what i usually do but i hope
you enjoyed it if you have any ideas on
strange groups me to investigate let me
know in the comments if you liked this
video and want to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way
oh and do check out the channel's merch
over at crowdmade we have beanies
t-shirts and hoodies links are in
description down below
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye